PLEASE DON'T DO THAT.
>> HERE AND NOW WITH REACTION,
THE AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK
HERE'S THE DEAL FORMER SENIOR
COUNSELOR TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
KILLIAN CONWAY ALONG WITH THE
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
OCASIO-CORTEZ FLEISCHER.
I WILL START WITH YOU KELLY IN.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT JEFF BEZOS, TH
MILLIONS HE GAVE TO JOE BIDEN
AND THE MILLIONS IS GIVEN DURIN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, FOR
HIM TO TAKE HIM IN SUCH A PUBLI
WAY IS REALLY SHOCKING.
IN FACT, I THINK IT SPEAKS TO
HIS NOT JUST DISILLUSIONMENT BU
TOTAL DISAPPOINTMENT IN THIS JO
BIDEN PRESIDENCY?
>> IT ALSO SPEAKS TO THE FACT
THAT SO MANY INDUSTRIES LIKE
MUSK, BASIS, AND OTHERS, SOME O
THE GREAT INNOVATORS OF OUR TIM
DID NOT WANT TO BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE AND ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT THIS PRESIDENT SAYS AND
DOES SO THEY DON'T RESPOND THEY
ARE SOMEWHAT CONSISTENT IN THEI
SILENCE.
IT ALSO IS QUITE STRIKING TO SE
A TWEET BY THE OIL AND GAS
ASSOCIATION IN RESPONSE TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S TWEET, THEY
SAID HEY, I HOPE WHATEVER WHITE
HOUSE INTERN WROTE THAT TWEET
WILL TAKE AN ECONOMIC ONE ON ON
COURSE WHEN HE OR SHE GETS TO
COLLEGE.
THAT SUGGEST THAT SUPPOSED TO B
SUBSTANTIVE THAT IT WAS SO OFF
THE MARK THAT EVEN JEFF BEZOS
SAID TO CLAP BACK AT THE
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT, LOOK, I
DON'T THINK IT'S A FAIR FIGHT
AND ANYONE'S EYES IF JOE BIDEN,
WHO HAS A 36 PERCENT APPROVAL
RATING DOWN FROM 54 PERCENT FRO
A YEAR AGO WHEN HE TOOK OFFICE,
I DON'T THINK IT'S A FAIR FIGHT
FOR HIM TO GO UP ELON MUSK OR
JEFF BEZOS.
THESE GUYS HAVE CREATED SO MUCH
WEALTH AND JOBS, AND THEY ARE
JUST NOT GOING TO WIN THAT
DEBATE.
>> I WILL ASK YOU THIS.
CLAIMING THAT MOM AND POP GAS
STATIONS, THAT HAVE TO MAKE
MONEY BY SELLING CIGARETTES AND
CANDY BARS, AND I HAVEN'T MET
ANYONE WHO IS A REALLY WEALTHY
GUY OR WOMAN, BLAMING THEM IS
REALLY, IT'S SO DISINGENUOUS.
IT IS SO UNFAIR AND IT JUST
AVOIDS THE REALITY OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN AMERICA TODAY.
>> MY FAVORITE PART OF THAT FEA
IS THE END WHEN HE SAID AND JUS
DO IT NOW.
WHO DOES HE THINK HE'S TALKING
TO?
AND HE DOES HE THINK HE IS?
THIS IS A FREE ECONOMY.
THE ECONOMY RESPONSE TO MARKET
IMPULSES.
IT SHOULD NEVER RESPOND TO THE
PRESIDENTS TWEET.
A LOT OF THEM ARE
FIRST-GENERATION AMERICANS WHO
ARE TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING.
THEY DON'T HAVE A MASSIVE PROFI
MARGINS, THEY ARE TRYING TO ON
LOCAL LEVEL.
GOD BLESS THEM, THAT IS PART OF
THE SPIRIT OF AMERICA.
THEY HAVE NEVER UNDERSTOOD THAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL INITIATIVE, THA
INDIVIDUAL INNOVATOR.
GET UP EARLY, GO TO BED LATE,
WORK ALL DAY IT MAKES AMERICA
WORK.
>> RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
SOMETHING NEW THAT WE ARE SEEIN
NOW IS HOMELESSNESS IS A RESULT
OF INFLATION.
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOSING THEIR
HOMES ARE NOT ABLE TO MAKE RENT
ARE NOW FINDING THEMSELVES
HOMELESS BECAUSE OF THIS
CONSISTENT RISE IN FOOD, GAS
PRICES, AND THEY ARE JUST NOT
BEING ABLE TO MEET THEIR BILLS
ARE TIGHT NEVER THOUGHT WE WOUL
SEE HOMELESSNESS BASED ON THE
INABILITY OF PEOPLE WHO HAD JOB
NOW TOP BEING ABLE TO EVEN KEEP
UP WITH THEIR OWN STANDARD OF
LIVING.
>> THAT IS THE THING, YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE A JOB, TWO OR
THREE JOBS IN THE HOUSEHOLD AND
THEY SAY THE JOB IS NOT EVEN
ENOUGH.
THEY CAN'T BE MAKE BASIC
EXPENSES.
THEY TALK TO A WOMAN WHO MADE
$100,000 LAST YEAR.
THIS YEAR SHE FELL BEHIND IN HE
RENT, HER FAMILY IS LIVING IN
THEIR HYUNDAI AND SHOWERING AT
THE GYM ENTERING TO GET MEALS
FROM DIFFERENT FAMILY MEMBERS.
BEFORE IF YOU LIKE YOUR LOST HE
JOB OR HAD AN A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY OR SOMETHING ELSE THA
WAS REALLY A BIG DEAL, MAY BE A
FELL BEHIND IN YOUR RENT, BUT
THE HOMELESSNESS NOW IS UP AMON
SINGLE MOMS, 15 STATES HAVE SEE
AN INCREASE IN THEIR WAIT LISTS
ARE DOUBLING AND TRIPLING.
THESE DECISIONS BY JOE BIDEN
HAVE CONSEQUENCES.
HIS APPROVAL RATING IS THE
LOWEST OF OBAMA, TERMS, OR HIS
AT THIS POINT BEFORE THE MIDTER
ELECTION.
JOE BIDEN IS PROBABLY LOOKING
AROUND SAYING HOW IT IS THAT
HAPPEN?
THE QUICK ANSWER, YOU EARNED IT.
YOU EVER YOU EARNED EVERY LOW
APPROVAL RATING.
PEOPLE OUR SUFFERING.
IT'S PEOPLE WHO HAD HOMES AND
RENTED OR OWN HOMES AND HAD JOB
NOT SO LONG AGO ARE NOW HOMELESS
.
>> IT'S KELLY AND IS RIGHT BRAD
NOT ONLY OWNS IT, BUT I THINK
PEOPLE REALIZE THAT IS WHY THE
NUMBER, 36 PERCENT, HIS APPROVA
RATING AND 88 PERCENT OF THE
COUNTRY THINGS WERE GOING IN TH
WRONG DIRECTION.
THEY ARE POINTING THE FINGER AT
JOE, AREN'T THEY?
>> IT'S NOT ONLY REPUBLICANS OR
INDEPENDENTS DOING IT BUT IF
YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT YOU HAVE TO
SCRATCH YOUR HEAD AND SAY WHAT
IS HE DONE FOR ME SINCE HE
BECAME PRESIDENT.
THERE'S ONLY TWO THINGS I CAN
THINK OF.
UNEMPLOYMENT REMAINS LOW, I
DON'T KNOW IF HE DOES DESERVES
THE CREDIT, THE NUMBER TWO IS
HE'S NOT MEAN TWEETING AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS COME FROM.
THEY CAN'T POINT TO THE ECONOMY
THEY CAN'T POINT TO INFLATION.
THEY CAN'T POINT TO LAW AND
ORDER, THEY CAN'T POINT TO CRIME
, THEY CAN'T POINT TO THE
BORDER, THEY CAN'T POINT TO THE
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN.
EVERYTHING JOE BIDEN HAS DONE
HAS HAD THE REVERSE MIDAS TOUCH.
IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT YOU HAVE T
SAY TO YOURSELF IS HE THE BEST
WE CAN DO?
CAN WE DO BETTER THAN AN 80
-YEAR-OLD CANDIDATE AFTER THIS
MIDTERM TO LEAD OUR PARTY INTO
THE 2024 ELECTION?
THEY ARE INCREASINGLY LEAVING
THE WAY SAYING NO YOU CAN'T